hi everyone welcome to another episode
of Science and Technology q a for kids
and others and I see a variety of
questions that have accumulated here so
let me try and uh take a few of these
um
there's a question here from Jimmy
could we be inside a black hole can
biological life survive inside a black
hole
well
so first of all
what is a black hole a black hole is
something where there's so much gravity
that even light can't escape from that
area so what happens is when you have
the Earth for example if you shoot a
rocket up from the earth if you don't
shoot it up fast enough the gravity of
the earth will just pull it back and it
will crash down on the Earth again
if you shoot it faster than 25 000 miles
an hour up from the earth it will escape
the gravity of the earth it goes fast
enough it has enough momentum that it
can break away from the the gravity of
the earth and just go off into space
every different kind of object depending
on its mass and how big it is will have
a different escape velocity so for
example the sun has an escape velocity
of maybe a hundred thousand miles an
hour our galaxy has an escape velocity
of I think about a million miles an hour
and so on
but what happens is if there's enough
mass and a small enough volume the small
enough sized object the escape Velocity
eventually becomes higher than the speed
of light so that means
because it seems to be a fact about
physics there are some footnotes to this
that come out of our our new models of
physics but basically nothing gets to go
faster than the speed of light
and so if you have something where the
the escape velocity is
the speed of light or larger that means
that even light even something which
goes as fast as light can't escape so
that means that there's this region of
space where anything that tries to get
out will be sort of pulled back in and
can never Escape
so in particular
in a black hole there's this thing
called The Event Horizon which is this
this place in space where it turns out
that any light that originates inside
the Event Horizon will always get pulled
back inside and will never escape and
everything outside the amount of horizon
can escape
and uh the it was very confusing to
people when black holes were first uh
kind of thought about
the the equations that describe the
structure of space-time the equations of
general relativity that were invented in
1915 by by Albert Einstein
um those equations kind of describe how
mass and energy deform the structure of
space-time and that deformation of the
structure of space-time is what leads to
gravity as soon as you kind of change
the shape of space you change kind of
the the the shortest the ways that
things go on shortest paths by deforming
how those shortest paths go it's
deflecting how sort of objects move
through space and that's kind of has the
effect of uh is is the is the thing that
leads to the force of gravity
but in any case those the equations of
general relativity
implied that you could get these funny
singularities these funny sort of one
over zero type things going on and
people were very confused actually
Robert Oppenheimer was one of the people
involved with this in the 1930s 19 to 19
early 1940s
um trying to sort of unravel what was
really going on in these cases where
there were these kind of one over zero
Infinity type singularities in in the
sort of structure implied for space-time
and people at first thought that well
you have this event horizon that as you
if you were in a spacecraft that was
kind of Falling Towards a black hole you
went through the eventual eyes and
people sort of thought oh something
terrible is going to happen at the Event
Horizon turns out that's not true turns
out you wouldn't even notice going
through the Event Horizon the only thing
that would happen is that the signals
you send out you wouldn't know you you'd
be waiting forever and ever for as you
you get close to the event horizon a
signal you send out is kind of pulled
back a bit so it takes longer to get out
than you might expect but eventually you
might send some signal out to some other
spacecraft or planet or whatever and
eventually somebody might reply and you
get get the signal back what happens is
you go inside the Event Horizon is that
the time for your signal to reach its
destination becomes infinite you'd never
get an answer back you wouldn't get you
wouldn't your signal would never would
never be able to reach the sort of the
uh the the sender but but you wouldn't
notice as you go through the Event
Horizon you wouldn't really notice
anything bad happened you'd it would
only be if you waited for signals to
come that you'd sent out to come back
they wouldn't ever come back
so this question was what's it like to
be inside a black hole well
as you pass through the Event Horizon
nothing much happens it's only kind of
in the Long View of history that you
would realize you were now kind of
nothing you said could ever be heard
outside so to speak
but then as you sort of uh you're sort
of falling into this black hole now
there's a bit of an embarrassing feature
about black holes which is the
mathematical theory that describes black
holes kind of tells you how event
Horizons work and things like that
they're not really tell you much about
what happens inside the Event Horizon in
fact as far as the mathematics is
concerned it doesn't really matter if
there's anything inside the Event
Horizon well pretty much anything inside
the Event Horizon in reality a black
hole is formed when a massive star
collapses and is pulled by the force of
its own gravity into this tiny area and
that's produces enough kind of mass and
a small enough volume that you get
larger than speed of light escape
velocity and you get a black hole but so
inside the Event Horizon of a black hole
you would normally you would think in
physically that what would happen is
what the way it will be formed is that
there's a collapsed star and there's all
kinds of stuff from the collapsed star
inside the Event Horizon
but
because you can't find out what's
happening inside the Event Horizon from
outside the Event Horizon because no
information about what's inside can get
out you don't really know there's a
collapsed star inside you might know
from the past that oh yeah we saw the
star it was collapsing now now that must
be what's inside this event horizon but
you can't know that from just seeing the
Event Horizon of the black hole
so that's that's sort of a uh so in the
mathematics of what goes on the
structure of the Event Horizon all those
kinds of things is quite independent of
what's inside it could be this this you
know there could be this whole
civilization that's going on inside
there could be they could have a whole
you know it could be the thing that's
this shape it's that shape it doesn't
matter outside it all just looks like
this kind of sphere of Event Horizon
well it's even more bizarre than that
because in the usual mathematical Theory
there can just be vacuum inside the
Event Horizon with one exception there
has to be some kind of puncture in the
structure of space-time there has to be
a single point at which the structure of
space-time has changed a single point at
which for example the curvature of
space-time becomes infinite now in our
models of space-time things are not
nearly as pathological as that and our
models there's there's this kind of
network that represents the structure of
space and space is ultimately composed
of these just individual points related
by The Edge business Network and so when
we say that what happens when you make
an event horizon for example is certain
features of that Network are actually
the certain features of the way that
Network progresses through time uh work
in a certain way and the what happens at
the center of the black hole where you
have this singularity in space time
um and and sort of the the traditional
view of space as a continuous thing the
only way you can deal with that is to
say there's a hole punched out of
space-time where there just is no space
time there it's just a it's just an
infinitesimally small hole but there's a
hole so in our models it doesn't quite
work that way you could have something
much more structure you can actually see
the structure of the network is
different as you get in towards the
singularity at the center of the black
hole but one feature of that Singularity
is for the simplest kind of black hole
at least is that time stops
so
in our model of physics what's happening
time is this sort of progressive
computation of the state of the universe
the next state of the universe the next
state of the universe always being
computed from the previous state and in
in sort of structurally what's happening
is you have this giant graph and at
every step
all the different pieces of this graph
are being Rewritten and so sort of the
progress of time is the progressive
rewriting of this graph and another
thing in the universe is a feature of
this graph every electron every whatever
they're all just features of this of the
structure of this graph and so time is
this progression of sort of the
rewriting of this graph okay so what
happens at these singularities in the
simplest kind of black hole non-rotating
black hole in the simplest kind of black
hole what happens is time just stops
so what does that mean it means that at
the center of the black hole there are
pieces of the network where no more
rewrite Supply there isn't another
rewrite that gets done it just stops
so it's um uh it's if if you were sort
of part of that it's kind of like your
mind just stops running your brain stops
running you you won't it's not like oh
I'm realizing I just froze you don't
realize anything there's no thinking
going on there's no there's no mind
there's no experience happening it just
time just stops
and in the uh so what happens in the
sort of traditional view of things is
the spacecraft that fell through the
Event Horizon eventually is led into
that Singularity at the center of the
black hole at which point time stops
and it it always after a limited time
the spacecraft always ends up at that
singular point at the center of the
black hole in our models it's a bit more
explicit what happens
um but the end result is uh at some
moment you the time is Frozen nothing
ever happens anymore so you don't know
what happened because time is Frozen for
you as it's frozen for everything else
so in this question of of can you sort
of lead a happy life inside a black hole
well up to a point eventually you die so
to speak eventually there's no more kind
of there's no more experience that
happens
um that that's the that's the case for
the simplest kind of black hole with the
other kind of black hole you get a more
bizarre thing still in rotating
bloodhouses that effectively are
rotating you get uh so the thing I just
described is called the space like
Singularity
um there's another kind of Singularity
called the time like Singularity where
instead of time stopping effectively
space has has stopped what does that
mean it means that the normally in space
you can move back and forth you can move
around it's there's extent to space
but in a time like Singularity there is
no extent to space space is
infinitesimally small and you are sort
of Trapped in this infinitesimally small
region of space where all that can ever
happen is the same thing keeps on
happening over and over again through
time and and that's kind of a different
so so there time is infinite but space
is is is infinitely small so that's a
different kind of Singularity that can
happen but in both of these cases it's
kind of not like you'd notice anything
really bad happened because you don't
get to notice anything because you're
kind of your mind is kind of Frozen at
that point
so but uh in in terms of of can can
there be a uh a sort of uh if you uh
often
a limited time everything comes to an
end
now for our universe could be the same
thing it could be that in our universe
we expand for a while and then gravity
pulls back the expansion of the universe
and eventually it goes crunch in a in a
big crunch that doesn't seem to be the
path that our universe is on based on
the speed at which the universe is
expanding and other kinds of things we
can measure it seems like we're just
going to get to the point where we're
just eventually coasting and going and
we're not we're not going to um we're
neither going to speed up in our
expansion nor are we going to sort of
turn around and Crush down again but if
we did it can still be the case in in
both scenarios that um uh sort of you
can end up with a situation where again
for the whole universe time eventually
ends
and where sort of we keep going for a
long time and then eventually it's all
over and time has ended the the
possibility where the universe just sort
of expands Forever at an increasing rate
you can get into a situation where it
expands forever but the rate increases
and eventually everything gets so far
apart that at least in the traditional
model the uh so far apart that kind of
nothing very interesting can happen
anymore I actually now that I think
about it in our models uh it doesn't it
would not really work that way it would
no longer it would not be the case that
that would be an approximation and if
you look below that approximation and
you look at the actual structure of
space-time there will still be features
of the actual structure of space-time
that it won't be the case that the thing
has become sort of uniform and boring
um and and in fact in our models again
uh even with the sort of the Big Crunch
scenario
um again it won't get as it won't get
the same way as it does in kind of the
the older models of physics where the
thing just sort of compresses to a point
and there's nothing more going on there
it's a little bit more structured than
that
so that that's uh uh a little bit of a
discussion about could we be you know
what's what's inside a black hole can
things survive in a black hole the
answer is yes but only for finite time
typically but we are you know our
universe may only survive for finite
time as well and there's an awful lot of
time before you know let's say our
universe survives for a trillion years
we're about 14 billion years in and we
can lead happy lives for an awfully long
time even if the actual lifetime of the
universe is quotes only a trillion years
so we're kind of existing in what one
can think of as kind of a we might think
we're existing in sort of the transient
before the real outcome of the universe
is known
um I don't think in our models for
example this idea that Things become
very different uh when the universe is
either crunched down or gets very big or
whatever else it doesn't it's a little
bit of a subtle thing because
what it means to an observer like us
today you know we're roughly a meter
tall give or take one and a half meters
tall whatever it is and to an observer
like us if we imagine what the universe
might be like when it's crunched down or
it's really big or whatever we say oh
that that doesn't look very interesting
that looks like nothing nothing that we
can kind of engage with but that's
because we're a meter and a half tall or
whatever and we have certain things we
can measure if we imagine sort of
projecting the future of uh humans not
really humans are very likely you know a
trillion years from now and we say well
what do we sense then well we're
probably not a meter and a half tall and
made up with you know biological
molecules and things like this and with
a different kind of Observer the
structure of the universe as it might
exist at that time in the distant future
can be perfectly exciting and
interesting even though to an observer
like us it isn't interesting so it's uh
that there's uh and the same through a
lot of these different kinds of things
the question of of is there kind of a uh
what's one's impression of what's going
on well it depends on what one is like
as an observer
um
let's see
oh boy a lot of black hole questions all
right let's let's take a look
at some of these
um
death sauce with something Trapped In
The Space Between The Event Horizon and
the singularity eventually be able to
escape
uh black holes the things I explained
there's actually more to the whole story
of black holes and one thing that
happens is quantum mechanics leads to
yet more bizarre effects around black
holes uh in our models it gets a little
bit clearer what's going on uh but it's
a bit complicated to explain in our
models there are many different Paths of
history for the universe and that's what
kind of corresponds to quantum mechanics
and what happens
in a black hole is there's an event
horizon for things moving through
physical space
there's a different what one can call
entanglement Horizon for things for sort
of things that correspond to different
parts of history and it's there's a
slightly longer story to explain the
picture but essentially what the the
well the end result is when you think
you formed a black hole where nothing
can escape there's sort of quantum
mechanical things going on that allow
things to escape and in the if you wait
sufficiently long you'll end up with the
the sort of the the thing where no black
hole ever really formed being what comes
out so one way that one sees that is
with Hawking radiation which is a
quantum mechanical effect which kind of
a picture of what's going on is
in the vacuum in quantum mechanics there
are continually particle anti-particle
pairs being formed and being destroyed
again at every moment everywhere in
space space is full of particle
antiparticle pairs they form they do get
destroyed they form they get destroyed
all the time uh and smaller and smaller
scales Etc et cetera et cetera in our
model to physics
that is really the there's this giant
Network and particles are features of
that Network and so as that Network gets
updated you can think of those updates
in terms of particles getting formed
particles getting destroyed but in the
end it's just a network getting updated
and that because it goes all the way
down even below the level where you can
kind of identify particles and
anti-particles and things like that so
in fact in our models it is the activity
in this network that knits together the
structure of space if it wasn't for that
activity two different places in space
would have no relation to each other
they wouldn't have there wouldn't be any
sense in which these things were
connected in which we could imagine
motion that goes from one to the other
and so on so in any case the this idea
that there's kind of this continual
particle anti-particle formation or
continual sort of updating of this
network that one can think of in terms
of particles and antibarticles happening
in the universe in around a black hole
kind of a a typical picture would be
that these particle antiparticle pairs
get informed and what happens if let's
say the antiparticle falls into the
black hole it gets formed and it's going
to annihilate again but before it
denialates again the antiparticle falls
into in through the Event Horizon and
can no longer escape again so that means
that the particle is just left hanging
on its own and that emerges as a piece
of radiation coming out from the black
hole because its partner that it would
have annihilated with again uh got
trapped inside the inside the Event
Horizon of the black hole so that's a
kind of a sort of radiation that emerges
from black holes and eventually
it will sort of uh mine the mass of the
black hole and eventually all of it will
turn into radiation that's a kind of a
strange picture of what's going on I
think a better picture which is a little
bit harder to understand perhaps it all
has to do with uh let's see at the as
you get to the event horizon of a black
hole
two yeah this this is where things get
kind of complicated in terms of what you
feel like as you're falling into a black
hole this is what what folks outside of
it think you're doing so what happens is
if you're falling into a black hole
you're just going along and you're
you're thinking a certain amount of
times elapsing it's not too much Etc et
cetera Etc
but to an observer far away you seem
like you're slowing down and slowing
down and slowing down you know what if
you had a clock that was ticking on your
spacecraft and somebody was observing
the ticking of that clock from far away
far away from the black hole it would be
as if that clock was ticking slower and
slower and slower and slower and slower
until eventually you just freeze to an
observer to the on the outside you just
freeze sort of at the at the surface of
the Event Horizon so for you you're like
oh I just fell into the Event Horizon to
an observer outside it's like well it's
an infinite amount of time the The
Observer is stuck the the spacecraft is
stuck at the Event Horizon and that's
kind of the flip around of the fact that
when you send a signal out
you it is a a limited time for you but
that time it's sort of an infinite time
for the outside world and that's kind of
why your signal never actually gets out
so to speak
it's why for example in black holes
words term invented in the
1950s 60s I guess
um by an American physicist called John
Wheeler in in Russian physics black
holes were called Frozen Stars
because of this effect that as you kind
of get to the outside it looks like sort
of everything freezes
so okay that that's what happens so to
an observer
on the far outside it freezes at that
level now there's another bizarre thing
that can happen which is that
um
when you think about these different
threads of history that originated that
exist in quantum mechanics
the big thing that happens
when we so the universe looked at sort
of from outside the universe there are
many paths of history in the universe
but to an observer embedded inside the
universe like us
our minds are also branching just like
the universe is branching into many
parts of History so we have this
question of what does a mind that's
branching think is happening when
observing a universe that is itself
branching
and we have the idea that definite
things happen so it's as if in our minds
we're conflating together all those
different parts of History it's a
non-trivial fact that we don't get lots
of confusions and inconsistencies by
conflating those things together but we
conflate those things together and
that's kind of how we go from the sort
of underlying Quantum many possible
parts of History to the definite things
happen kind of kind of situation
well the ability for us to knit those
parts of History together and conclude
that something definite happens
shouldn't be taken for granted and in
fact what happens at the entanglement
Horizon as we call it around a black
hole and this is part of things that
have emerged from our physics project
um understanding all of this stuff that
at the entanglement Horizon what happens
is that an observer can no longer knit
together in finite time all of these
different Paths of History just like one
can't kind of connect uh one can't send
signals out and so on one also can't
kind of come to a definite conclusion
about which path of History one was on
so it's it's as if for us we can say yes
we're going to conflate these parts of
History we're going to say a definite
thing happened but to an observer at the
entanglement Horizon around a black hole
the the entanglement Horizons are
probably outside of the Event Horizon
um at that when the Observer reaches
that they get to the point where they
can no longer sort of form a classical
thought they can no longer conclude with
any definiteness what happened and I
think that's what's going on when one
looks at kind of a black hole it sort of
forms
but sort of one is if one's an observer
right there one kind of isn't really
sure it Formed because one can't form
the sort of classical thought to know
what happened and eventually that what
the black hole has disintegrated again
and it's like well I don't really know
what happened because I couldn't really
form a classical thought to know what
happened and that's that's roughly the
picture of what goes on there
let's see
um
Christian asks
uh about the stopping of time in a black
hole is this the case also for string
theory
um so there is a uh one of the things
that was discovered actually by a friend
of mine
um when was it 20 years ago maybe
um was
that
um
in string theory
there's a way to
sort of if you think about the analog of
a black hole in string theory
there's some
uh
a way to understand the properties of a
black hole in terms of the structure of
strings so maybe I should explain what
what strength there is and how how
strings work
um
let's see string theory has a weird
weird history
because it's basically had three
different epochs
where the same mathematics was used for
three completely different purposes so
it's rather confusing as you start
talking about it
but
in a first approximation let's talk
about how how String Theory works
so
in theory of in Quantum Mechanics for
example one of the things one wants to
talk about is how do particles behave
what's a particle an electron a photon a
quark
these are particles that
have
where we have a sort of picture that
there are all these many parts of
History we have this way of of
representing what is the sort of
amplitude roughly probability for a
particle to be found in different places
in space and so on
in the end uh what happens for these
particles is that one has certain rules
for how particles can move through space
so that these things called wave
equations for example and different
kinds of particles obey different wave
equations like an electron a bay is a
thing called the Dirac equation which is
just some mathematical equation which
describes how sort of the amplitude of
these different parts of History which
assign different positions to the
electron how that amplitude evolves
through time and in space
and for example a photon has a different
wave equation that it satisfies they're
different because the particles are just
they have a different intrinsic Spin and
that kind of the spin determines kind of
which kind of wave equation they satisfy
but so that's kind of this theory of how
particles work in terms of these wave
equations and if you look in Space the
particle an electron for example in
traditional physics not in our models
but but in traditional physics an
electron is a point particle it has
absolutely no extent it's infinitely
small
same with the photon same with the quark
a proton for example it's pretty big a
proton is measurable size we know how
big it is an electron so far as any
experiment has shown so far the electron
is infinitely small in our models the
physics the electron is not infinitely
small but it's really really small
compared to anything that we can measure
with particle accelerators and so on
today
so
an electron is essentially a point
particle
in space if we look at it through time
it traces out what one can call a world
line if one just says it once if one
looks at sort of Imagine space is
two-dimensional and we just make a stack
of configurations of space going down in
the third dimension with time then the
path of a particle will just be a line
in the space-time structure
so particles make lines and space time
and okay so that's that's a fine thing
so now the question is well what if we
had something that wasn't a point
particle what if we had a bigger object
what if we had something that was
extended somehow in space-time
well for many many years there were was
a lot of difficulty understanding what
that could possibly be like because a
lot of the rules about quantum mechanics
and relativity and so on they get very
very confused when you deal with
extended objects I'll give you an
example of of how things get confused
you've got an extended object you've got
an arm and the arm it's an extended
thing it's swinging around and but it's
a rigid arm kind of swinging around in
space you say well let's make it longer
and longer and longer arm but it's rigid
well eventually that arm the tip of the
arm if it gets long enough will be going
faster than the speed of light
but that can't happen that's not how
things work
so then you have to say well what
happens to this arm well the answer is
in reality it can't be rigid the the
mechanical forces that would build up to
make the tip of the arm go as much as
fast as the speed of light are such that
the arm could never stay together if
it's made of a metal or made of atoms or
made of some carbon nanotube or whatever
whatever it's made of there are infinite
forces that get developed and the thing
could never stay together so there's
sort of you can't think about an
extended object that's kind of like a
long arm or something rigid thing that
doesn't end up being compatible with
relativity Theory and uh people had a
long a lot of difficulties seeing how do
you deal with extended objects okay so
it was realized that um you could have a
kind of a string that was an extended
object in in the space that kind of
where sort of the the the pieces of it
sort of all go at the speed of light and
this string just as a particle traces
out a line in space this time a string
traces out a world sheet in space-time
and so then the question is well okay
that's that's well and good can we make
that can we make kind of a wave equation
like thing for that string that's you
know kind of moving at the speed of
light and the pieces of it are moving at
the speed of light and so on can we make
something a consistent kind of wave
equation like thing
and this is where things got complicated
and people realized that well actually
uh no you couldn't really quite do that
but there was this cool thing that
happened if the University of space
happened to be 26 dimensional
oh in some cases 10 dimensional then it
did work out that you couldn't get see
what what ended up happening was that
inevitably as the string moved through
space-time there would be kind of uh
features of the string that move faster
than the speed of light that turned out
to be an inevitable feature but somehow
that because of the way the mathematics
works out in let's say 26 Dimensions the
the sort of the things that lead to
those those kind of uh fast and the
speed of light pieces they somehow
cancel out and so it's like well maybe
actually the universe is 26 dimensional
and maybe those extra you know 24
Dimensions or so 20 22 Dimensions or
whatever maybe or 23 Dimensions
depending on how you're counting things
maybe the reason we don't see those is
that those dimensions are curled up
really small that they're that and that
all that happens is that in those
Dimensions it's kind of like that that
time like Singularity I was talking
about earlier in those Dimensions space
isn't really Extended space has just
curled up and it's only in the three
dimensions of ordinary space that it's
extended and we can move around so that
that's kind of the um uh that's sort of
a a basic um
picture of um uh of kind of the setup
now there are a lot of details about
this and about different kinds of
strings and different kinds of um uh the
the strings that like to live in 10
dimensions and in 26 Dimensions the
strings that correspond to kind of a bit
like a generalization of a photon versus
the strings that correspond to a bit
like the generalization of an electron
there's this idea of supersymmetry uh so
gosh well you know they're things that
are symmetrical like you take a sphere
and you rotate it and however you rotate
it it's always going to look like a
sphere if you have a cylinder instead
well you can rotate the cylinder around
its axis but if you turn the cylinder
not around its axis it's not the same
thing anymore
so there's lots of kinds of Notions of
symmetry like that one of the more
interesting kinds of symmetry is that is
a uh well there are symmetries that are
associated with kind of the the uh
features of of particles and so on
um
for example well let's see in um
uh
well there there are cases where well
for example particles versus
antiparticles you can think there's sort
of a discrete symmetry transformation
instead of a with a sphere where you can
turn it to any angle you could say well
let's say we've got a square for example
and we can reflect the square as it's a
discrete thing it you know with that
discrete transformation or we can turn
it through 90 degrees with that discrete
transformation it turns into itself
again well there's a similar kind of
thing with particles and antiparticles
you can kind of apply charge conjugation
turn a particle into an anti-particle
applied again the antiparticle turns
back into a particle again and when I
say apply I just mean consider applying
it there's no machine that will apply
charge conjugation there is a machine
that will turn something so to speak
through a certain angle but there isn't
these these kinds of things that um
these so-called internal symmetries
they're not things where a machine like
that can make that transformation
it's actually a little bit more subtle
than that because the interaction uh
this is a a subtle mess about how gauge
theories work and so on but let's not go
down that particular Rabbit Hole the um
but in in a there is this idea of super
symmetry in which things that are like
photons which um sort of turn into
things that are like electrons just as
sort of a a particle could turn into its
anti-particles so there are these
Transformations that turn one of those
into the other and that's they kind of
relate things like photons to things
like electrons and kind of that story
plays into the kind of string
generalizations of things like electrons
and things like photons and uh that
makes a very lovely theory that has a
lot of very interesting mathematical
properties uh we kind of suspect that in
the end certain features of that theory
correspond to features of our models of
physics
and uh there are
um
let's see it's kind of a question of
boy This is complicated
um
well in our models of physics we talked
about how there's this kind of giant
Network that's progressively getting
Rewritten according to certain rules
but in the most General case you can use
any rule you can imagine you can just
apply all these different rules
you make this thing we call a rouliad
which is this kind of entangled limit of
all possible computational processes and
the the tricky thing is that we are
embedded in this ruly ad we are
observers within the rouliad observing
the rouliad and that sort of
self-observation when we are observers
with certain properties causes us to
believe certain things about what we
observe and the things we believe
correspond to laws of physics
the way in which we kind of parse out
what we're observing in this kind of
entangled limit of all possible
computations there are different ways to
pass that out we could say well there's
this state of the universe and then
there's another state of the universe at
a successive time there are particular
rules for the University being followed
there are these different rules followed
at the different possible rules we can
follow and so on there are different
ways to slice up the rouliad our guess
is that string theory corresponds to an
approximation to one way to slice up the
rouliad and that this when I talked
about these kind of compactified
dimensions and so on that's a particular
kind of way to uh to sort of arrange the
things in the rouliad so that we can
organize them to to kind of compress the
amount of information associated with
them so that we can kind of say oh yes
we can see what's going on it's not just
this big complicated mess and our guess
is that there are certain conditions
about how in order to get consistency in
the way that slicing works that
corresponds to these things that lead to
these implications about particular
dimensions and string theory and so on
that's sort of still somewhat of a guess
and there's lots of mathematical physics
to work through to see exactly how that
works boy this got kind of complicated
um
let's see
okay Technic is asking a rather
technical question what are the
implications of a naked black hole one
without an event horizon
okay so I mentioned that in the center
of a black hole in the traditional view
of physics the there's sort of a an
infinitesimal Point punched out of
space-time
now normally you can't tell it's there
because it's hidden behind an event
horizon and people have believed that
there will be no naked singularities
that it wouldn't be possible to set
things up so that you could form the
singularity but not form an event
horizon there was discovered maybe 15
years ago that there is an elaborate
procedure where you can essentially
carefully orchestrate what happens in
space-time so that you form a
singularity but you carefully avoid
forming an event horizon now there's a
lot of tricky aspects to this because
event Horizons are really you don't know
whether you've formed an event horizon
until an infinite time has passed
they're really a story of infinite time
uh it's an infinite time question
because you could say well you know I
didn't really get an event horizon just
if I waited long enough I'd be able to
get through it's a it's an infinite time
question whether an event horizon is
formed
and this this question about whether you
can form this thing which has no event
horizon or just a singularity it it
seems to be the case that sort of the
formation of a naked Singularity is
something similar to making something of
zero temperature so normally you have
all these molecules bouncing around and
in a material and if you try and do
reduce the temperature what you're
trying to do is make all those molecules
you're trying to just stop every
molecule you're trying to you know do
something where you pick every molecule
and you stop it and there are different
ways to do that more in bulk but what's
known the third law of thermodynamics
basically is the statement that there's
no way to get to Absolute Zero by a
finite number of steps
you know every time you've kind of you
know you've stopped one molecule or
you've got to stop another one you've
got to stop another one
Etc et cetera et cetera there's no way
to with a sort of in in my way of
thinking about this with sort of finite
computational ability effort to stop all
the molecules you'd have to sort of
predict where every single molecule was
and zap everyone to stop it well I think
the same thing happens with the
formation of naked singularities that
basically it's the same kind of thing
that you'd have to be able to break out
of kind of all the computational
complexity of the structure of
space-time to be able to carefully
orchestrate things so that you wind up
with this pure naked Singularity and so
I think what happens is that in in
space-time
you have all this sort of bubbling
around of all these rewritings of this
network and so on and you'd have to kind
of orchestrate it so that you just
carefully navigate things so that you
have exactly the right set of rewritings
so that you have this pure place where
time stopped and there's nothing sort of
around it and the claim is that you can
only do that you can't do that with a
finite amount of computation that you'd
have to kind of be dealing with every
individual atom of space separately and
sort of computing how it works the
problem is we're embedded in the
universe so the only way we get to do
those computations is by using the stuff
of the universe to do it and so we never
get to have enough computational ability
to be able to sort of untangle things to
the point where we can get to that naked
Singularity so that's my guess is that
it's kind of like in thermodynamics like
the inability to get to something like
absolute zero you similarly can't get to
a thing where just in the universe at
Large there's a place where time stopped
and you can kind of I mean it it's you
know where and you can sort of get to it
so to speak now even even when you
imagine a place where time stopped
you know by the time you get to it time
has stopped for you so you never get to
get out of it so it's all a bit bit
difficult to to untangle but I think
that's the basic idea
let's see Marcus comments
um
about uh when a black hole eats more
stuff it gets bigger so where's the
singularity so the singularity is at the
center of the black hole the in the
traditional view of physics it's a
vacuum solution to the Einstein
equations the the thing that this most
simple simple description of a black
hole but what happens is there's this
sort of place punched out of the
universe right at the center
um and uh it's the the um
the sort of
well sounds very silly doesn't it they
say there's an amount punched out of the
universe but there can be more punched
out of the universe but it's still an
infinitesimal point the mass parameter
of a black hole is a parameter
associated with that thing that got
punched out of the universe it's kind of
a weird setup in our models of physics
it's much cleaner it's much more there's
a much more direct interpretation of the
fact that the mass associated with the
black hole has to do with essentially
the activity of uh of this rewrites in
the network inside the black hole so
what's happening in our models is
there's kind of the presence of a large
amount of mass is the presence of many
rewrites spaces being sort of intensely
uh sort of bubbling around in a very
intense way getting knitted together in
a very intense way that's what mass and
energy are and that's what in the end
that a different mass of black hole is
one where there's different amounts of
that activity going on in the in the
structure of space inside the Event
Horizon
ah let's see
um
uh buildings comments that mass and
matter and antimatter both have positive
Mass
um so why doesn't Hawking radiation
increase the mass of alcohol where it
decreases it because because whether you
are emitting matter or antimatter you're
emitting positive mass and so that that
comes off the kind of balance sheet of
the black holes mass and you're
decreasing the mass of the black hole
because things are escaping away
a question of how small from storen how
question how small can a black hole be
well we don't know in our models of
physics
black holes can be really small because
they can be little features of space so
here's the thing that I suspect I
suspect that electrons are basically
black holes
and that an electron is essentially a
feature of space-time just as a great
big black hole is a feature effect
feature of space-time
an electron is also just a feature of
space-time it has nothing in it other
than being kind of this this lump of
space-time it's kind of like in a fluid
like water you can have an Eddy just
water circulating around and there's you
know you can point to that Eddy and say
oh it moved around but there's nothing
in the Eddy other than a bunch of
molecules that happen to be kind of
coherent coordinated in the motion that
they're going through and that's what I
think things like electrons are and I
think there's a very close analogy
between a black hole where there's sort
of this definite structure the space
that that forms the cement Horizon and
so on an electron where I think there's
also a definite structure to space and
kind of traditional physics electrons
are Point particles where there's just
no internal structure I don't think
that's right I think there is internal
structure and but one of the things
that's interesting is that to the
outside world just like in a black hole
the outside to the outside world all you
see is Event Horizon The Event Horizon
sort of featureless and that means all
you know about the black hole is things
like what it's masses what it's
effective angular momentum spin is and
things like this you don't really know
it's not like you can say well that's a
black hole that is this shape or that
shape no they're all kind of the same
they're all the sort of perfect shape to
the outside world one of the things
that's always been mysterious about
electrons is that they all seem to be
the same it's kind of like there's only
every electron in the universe seems
like it's the same they can have
different energies momentum things like
that but otherwise they're all the same
they all have the same mass they all
have the same you know other properties
and so on
and you know one of the more bizarre
theories about why that might be the
case
uh theory that um
was circulating in the 1940s was the
theory maybe there's just one electron
in the universe and maybe that electron
is going forwards in time then zipping
backwards in time and going forwards in
time again it's just sort of knitting
through and we are existing at a
particular time and the electron is just
sort of zipping back and forth in time
and there's just one of it kind of like
in in computer science you talk about
Turing machines where this is one head
where where activity happens that might
be the case with electrons turns out
that theory doesn't really work but so
you still are left with the question why
is there only why is why is every
electron in the universe the same
well you know I think in in our models
that what's happening is it's kind of
like you can say well I'm not I make a
knot in a rope
I can make the rope in lots of different
configurations but it's a definite kind
of knot there's a definite structure to
that knot even though the Rope may have
a slightly different form when I kind of
pull on the ends I can see it's it's
ultimately the same kind of knot it has
the same topological structure and we
suspect that that's sort of in some
sense why kind of all the electrons are
the same is because even though their
details might somehow be different
particularly inside some analog of an
event horizon that at some sort of large
topological scale they are all the same
and so if you ask what's the smallest
possible black hole it might be that
basically an electron is such a thing
but in any case in our models of physics
you can have things like black holes on
a pretty small scale I think uh that
that are pretty you know comparable to
the the distance the elementary length
you know the the uh a proton for example
is maybe uh a um uh
10 to the minus 15 meters a um
a million billionth of a meter across
um so but an electron is certainly
smaller than 10 to the minus 20 10 to
the minus 21 meters and in our models of
physics it's probably
more like uh 10 to the minus 80 meters
across so very very tiny and the
elementary length might be 10 to the
minus 90 meters so in a single electron
there might be 10 to the 10 sort of uh
Elementary lengths in space there might
be all that structure inside an electron
which kind of suggests there might be
some particles that are even smaller and
lighter than electrons and that's a
separate story about about what might
what might happen there
but um
let's see I think the so in some sense
there may be little tiny black holes
being
um it's uh you know that that the whole
structure of space-time just as there
are a little particle anti-particle
pairs that are being formed all the time
you can kind of think about there being
little sort of black hole kind of
anti-black hole pairs being formed
that's kind of you know one way to
describe the kind of bubbling around
with face time now you know what black
holes are you know is there a for
example in the early Universe could
there be a whole spectrum of black holes
a whole distribution of sizes of black
holes formed almost certainly the answer
is yes
there was recently an experiment based
on looking at the timings for pulsars
and kind of watching gravitational waves
uh that might have uh existed from the
early Universe kind of go through and
affect different pulsars for I don't
know 20 pulsars or something and as the
gravitational wave goes through it
changes the timing of the Pulsar just
slightly and by correlating all those
timings you can get a sense of of sort
of uh primordial gravitational waves
that might be sort of existing in the
universe today
um and um
that's a um uh but but you can imagine a
whole spectrum of black holes formed
from the in the early universe
um
lucky us do you think it will ever be
possible to reproduce a black hole in a
lab for practical research and
experimentation
people there are all kinds of
mathematical analogs of black holes that
are quite easy to make actually in fluid
mechanics and quantum mechanics and so
on there there are analogs but if you
say can we take a piece of space-time
and kind of curl it up to make a black
hole or maybe electrons are black holes
in which case we've got plenty of them
um I think sort of being able to make a
black hole
from
in the most traditional kind of black
hole I don't see a path for being able
to make that in in a kind of a lab
setting that's probably just as well
because even a very small black hole
kind of going through the Earth would
make you know would wreak havoc on
everything and the Earth would just get
sucked into the black hole and so on so
it's probably just as well that that
doesn't seem to be doesn't seem to be a
feasible thing to do in the current
Universe unless it turns out that
particles basically are black holes in
which case there's a whole different
story and the question of whether we
will eventually be able to simulate I
mean we what we've been doing recently
in recent times is simulating the
structure of space-time in our Network
models of space and seeing how black
holes work in those in that situation
and seeing how we can get very very tiny
black holes that we can simulate you
know kind of on a laptop and a black
hole that has you know 10 000 nodes of
space 10 000 atoms of space in it
absolutely you know ridiculously small
compared to real black holes that make
might have 10 to the 200 atoms of space
in them but we can see many features of
sort of big black holes already at this
uh these black holes that are very tiny
that's a sort of laptop simulatable and
we can see these black holes merge as we
know they do about once a week in our
universe us and produce gravitational
radiation Etc et cetera et cetera
let's see
um Philip asks what is spinning in a
spinning black hole it's a can of worms
the
it's really just a mathematical
parameter
when we talk about things spinning
the it's
as far as the actual black hole itself
is concerned
it's just a mathematical parameter but
that mathematical parameter has a
consequence
and as a consequence it's a phenomenon
called frame dragging
and what happens is
oh boy you guys ask me non-trivial
questions here
um the um
what happens is
in
in a black hole there's a question of
sort of
where are the gravitational field lines
what what what effect does the
gravitational field of a black hole have
on a material object like a like a a
drop of liquid for example well
sometimes the um uh
let's see how to think about this well
essentially there are tidal forces just
like there are on the Earth from the
Moon and the Sun and so on that elongate
that drop the the there's kind of
there's a there's more gravity kind of
on the inside and there's less gravity
on the outside and so the blob will kind
of elongate
and roughly what happens is that in a
black hole the so-called cursed solution
to the Einstein equations that has this
this spin parameter usually called J
um in that solution what happens is that
instead of things being sort of uh
symmetrically pulled in they are kind of
dragged so that they get so that they
get kind of um so they get uh so it's as
if they were kind of spinning around the
black holes it's actually a little bit
more complicated than this what happens
is the um the paths for light rays end
up uh you can think about kind of
plotting and space-time the parts that
light rays go this form so-called light
cones where you can have a light rays
are produced at some point and they go
outwards in space and they if you're
plotting them with time they go outwards
kind of in a cone that you form a cone
in space-time and so what happens is
that cone gets tipped in um uh near a
black hole and the way it gets tipped is
kind of like it's getting tipped at
different angles as you go around the
black hole it's sort of as if it's being
dragged around as a black hole is
rotating but there isn't really there's
nothing about the black hole itself
that's rotating it just makes things
around it rotate in some sense
Michael asks black holes have a charge
can the effect of the charge propagate
out of the black hole the photons cannot
escape the answer is black holes can
have a charge just like they have a a j
parameter that is like an angle momentum
they can have a charge parameter as a
thing called the ryzen Nordstrom
solution to the Einstein equations which
is a black hole that has charge
um the
how does that work
well
essentially what's happening is
just as the gravitational field so you
could say
if you know in my kind of picture of how
a black hole Works where nothing escapes
the black hole because there's nothing
goes faster than the speed of light and
and the black hole sort of pulls back in
things going going even at the speed of
light you could say if you wanted to be
difficult but what about the gravitons
that make up the gravitational field why
aren't the gravitons pulled back into
the black hole just like everything else
is pulled black into the black hole
well that's subtle it's really this
picture of things escaping from black
holes and and so on really isn't quite
the right picture black holes can a
better thought about as as just these
features of the structure of space-time
and that's just sort of a picture for
how to think about them and so you know
just gravitons are not pulled back into
the back hole and Nora photons in that
at the type of photon that makes a
static uh electric field
just as okay so a graviton if you were
to have a gravitational wave that in
that started inside the black hole it
would get pulled back into the black
hole just like a a photon that starts
inside the black hole gets pulled back
into the black hole
but okay now it gets a bit subtle
because a static gravitational field a
static electric field
these are sort of formed from gravitons
and photons but they're formed from
virtual gravitons and photons and they
don't have the same feature that you can
kind of Trace them in space and time
they're things that uh
it's really
how to think about this
some level it's a kind of a feature of
quantum mechanics but
in
there isn't the same kind of idea that
there's motion of the photon when you
have a static electric field you can
think about the electric field as being
associated with the exchange of virtual
photons and virtual photons going from
one charge to the other charge and so on
but
it doesn't have the same character of
being kind of a thing moving from here
to there
it's kind of subtle and I'm not sure I
actually haven't thought about this uh
with any Clarity let's see
um how to explain this
I'm not sure I'm going to I mean in the
in the mathematics of what goes on it's
rather it's fairly straightforward but
I'm not sure there's a there's a picture
like this that really Nails it in a in a
good way that sort of connects these
virtual particles that exist sort of
independent of time with these things
that have emotion that happens in time
so to speak
let's see
uh
Emery asks is a kind of a history of
Science question why are they named
black holes not after the people who
found discover this phenomenon well you
know it took a long time for the for
this phenomenon to become clear what the
heck it was and people really were
confused I mean the original discovery
that there was this particular solution
to the Einstein equations came in 1916
um but it wasn't until the 1960s that
people understood uh kind of something
about what the phenomenon of the black
hole was and that was a very slow
process involving many different people
and sort of a long progress of of
mathematical development
uh
let's see well I I think I almost ran
out of time but we've been talking about
black holes all this time we were kind
of dragged into the into the eventual
rising of a black hole or something
um let me just try and address a couple
more
questions
um
Aaron asks
we're going very different kind of
question could lasers be used to display
an advertisement or perhaps a clock or
something else on the moon
um can high bandwidth internet
connections be bounced off reflectors on
the moon
so
the answer is
you can see laser light that has been
reflected from the Moon
in fact the Apollo Astronauts put Luna
laser retro reflectors on the moon that
have little uh glass spheres in them
laser light falls on the reflector it
gets reflected back
here's the problem
lasers you should shoot a laser from the
Earth
the beam of the laser gradually spreads
out so even though it was a very intense
laser that might have had a spot that
was just a centimeter across on the
Earth by the time it gets to the Moon
it'll be a couple of kilometers across I
think the best lasers right now the
spread by the time you get to the moon
is on the order of a kilometer so
there's much less intensity in the light
by the time you get there if you could
keep the laser light kind of um well
collimated uh you know really keep it
together until it gets to the moon and
then you're Illuminating Moon Rock and
you know the well if you hit the laser
that's a reflector you'll get you know
you'll get the laser reflected precisely
back but mostly you'll hit lunar
regolith just Moon soil so to speak moon
rock
and that consists of these tiny little
sand like granules and when light hits
those it hits in One Direction and it's
it's uh it's a it's like like many kinds
of surfaces that aren't mirrors it's
it's a so-called lambushing reflector
it's um it light comes in and the light
that comes out is kind of spread in all
directions that's a typical thing and
the Albedo of the Moon that is if you
send in a certain amount of Light how
much light comes back out as I think
about one-tenth so you shine in a
certain amount of light the surface of
the Moon is pretty black only one tenth
of the light comes back out you know if
you have a mirror it's Albedo as one
because any light you shine on the
mirror if it's a perfect mirror comes
right back out again
um and uh different materials have
different albedos the Moon is actually
pretty pretty pretty black
um but one tenth of the light coming
from the Sun being reflected back to us
makes the Moon look bright in the sky at
night
so
it um so what happens
is that you have a laser you shine it on
the moon you've got a two kilometer
sized spot it's hard to have enough
intensity there to to really be able to
see anything from that for example the
naked eye what limits the um
uh the the amount of how unspread a
laser gets
has to do with the the way a laser
cavity works and um
uh let me see
the
in a laser you've got kind of light
bouncing back and forth and the way a
laser works the word laser stands for
light amplification by stimulated
emission of radiation roughly you have
this cavity with with mirrors at the at
the ends and so on and light is bouncing
backwards and forwards in this cavity
and it's gradually getting Amplified uh
through a process we can talk about it's
related to Bose Einstein condensation uh
there's this quantum mechanical process
by which photons kind of like to all be
in the same state and you can kind of
uh you can do this phenomenon of
stimulated emission where the presence
of photons gets there to be more photons
in the same state but anyway bottom line
is you've got these photons bouncing
backwards and forwards in this cavity
that makes the laser and the sort of
best thing you can get is a single mode
of the electromagnetic field so so it's
like you have a string and you can pluck
the string and you can get the string to
have just sort of one peak in the middle
between the places where you're holding
it or you can have two peaks or Three
Peaks or Four Peaks there's a different
harmonics
um they make for a different you know
frequency of sound if you made sound
from the from the string and so on but
it's the same kind of thing with light
you can have just sort of a single mode
of light in the laser cavity and that's
the thing that will get you the best uh
the the least spreading of laser light
but then the amount of spreading is
determined by features of the cavity and
there's a certain inevitable amount of
spreading I mean the fancy math version
of this these are I guess you can make
so-called gaussian
um
gaussian modes and there's a certain
spreading rate that is determined by the
process of diffraction and light that
determines how much the the thing will
spread out
um and I don't know exactly what's
involved in making maybe if you have a
bigger cavity you can make there be less
spreading it's kind of like a like the
reverse of a telescope where
um the uh the the spreading angle is
proportional the wavelength divided by
the size of the telescope
so you can get a a better a more precise
telescope by having a bigger telescope
there's less diffraction limit for the
telescope if it's bigger and I think
maybe the same thing is true with lasers
so if you have a big enough one maybe
you can get the thing to spread less
but so that would be the way of kind of
doing skywriting on the moon I think
it's sort of nearer term people think
about uh putting things in Earth orbit
and having things that re-enter the
Earth's atmosphere and burn up just like
micrometer meteorites burn up but you
can kind of you know release something
from a satellite and you can have this
whole kind of uh collection of pieces of
dust that you can see as they enter the
Earth's atmosphere because they will
burn up and they will they'll emit light
as they burn up and if you change the
the chemical uh constitution of of those
things you can get for example different
colors and you can imagine that if you
have sort of the satellite that's laying
stuff out that um uh
you can kind of skywrite in in Earth
orbit so to speak actually there was a
company that was trying to make that
work because it's like six seven years
ago I'm not sure exactly who you have to
get approval from to um uh to write a
big message in in space because the um
uh kind of the the sort of the airspace
of a country for example doesn't extend
infinitely far out so there are various
outer space treaties that I don't know
exactly how they apply to advertising in
space or exactly who would get upset
um if you start writing your ad in space
so to speak
um
let's see
let's see well I should probably um
oh M rudos if the moon is responsible
for tides on the earth can the Earth be
responsible for movement of moon dust
the answer is yes
the the Earth raises a tide on the moon
just as the moon raises the tide on the
Earth
but the tide on the earth most of the
tide on the Earth
is obvious because there's water on the
earth and that water can actually be
raised up on the side of the earth
nearer the moon and it goes further away
on the side of the earth that's further
from the Moon there is also a solid tide
on the earth that same effect of kind of
the squishing of the earth happens to
the solid rock of the Earth but it's a
much smaller effect than the uh than the
tide on um uh and that you can see in
the liquid water on the Earth
on the moon the Earth raises a solid
tide on on the moon and so the Moon is
continually kind of squished a bit by
the tides that are raised by the earth
now there's a satellite of Jupiter or
Saturn which has strong enough
um
uh solid Tides associated with I think
it's a moon of Jupiter
now I'm going to show my lack of
astronomy noise I think it's maybe IO
not sure that has strong enough uh solid
tides that they actually produce Heating
in the in the in the in the moon and
that heating produces volcanoes and all
kinds of stuff so you can have enough
squishing from tidal forces to have
those kinds of effects but for the moon
uh we don't have that kind of the earth
doesn't have that kind of effect if you
ask the question does uh you know if you
leave your footprint on the moon is it
going to stay forever is it going to be
there billions of years from now the
answer is it seems that the answer is
yes it isn't the case that the little
pieces of dust on the moon move around
now there is an effect
that the solar wind uh there's a stream
of particles just like this light that
comes from the sun there is also a
stream of protons and electrons that
come from the Sun and those things
stream into the atmosphere of the Earth
um they are ultimately responsible for
producing
um things like the Aurora but on the
moon they're continually sort of
bombarding the lunar surface Moon
doesn't have an atmosphere so all those
particles just come crashing down to the
surface and that seems to kind of bleach
the surface of the Moon
um progressively over time it doesn't
have the opportunity to move around
actual particles of kind of Moon dust
but it does seem to sort of in a sense
chemically or physically bleach those
things and so if you see kind of
features of the Moon that have been
created recently like places where a
spacecraft crashed into the moon
um the you know as a little crater over
the course of a few decades there will
be sort of a bleaching that happens
there well you can you can tell that
there was a there was so when the
spacecraft crashes into the Moon it
exposes layers of moon rock that have
not seen the Sun or anything for
billions of years and those turn out to
be sort of a different color but over
the course of decades they get sort of
bleached back into the same color so
there is an effect like that but it's
not one that can I think move around the
actual particles of moon dust and so you
put your footprint on the moon unless
some tourist comes and erases it uh you
know it's going to be there for a really
really long time
uh
side comments buying an ad that burns up
upon re-entry sounds incredibly wasteful
well you know it seems like you might
say buying an ad that disappears uh you
know when you uh click somewhere else is
also wasteful you know I think it's all
about
um uh what people notice and I suppose
you know you would hope that the kind of
the ad that says I don't know what the
ad would be an ad for I don't know what
people advertise for these days I'm not
in that many venues where there's tons
of advertising
um or if I am
I kind of block it out which is terrible
but any case
um but you know if it the the classic
will be buy coke or something and I
think one can be fairly certain that if
somebody did a a giant buy coke visible
in the sky you know at night from all
over North America that people will be
talking about that for a long time they
might be complaining about it for a long
time but they'd be talking about it for
a long time for sure so there would be
even though it burnt up in a matter of
uh 15 minutes or something it would
still be a subject of conversation for
um for many years to come
let's see
all right maybe one or two more
questions here
Stephen asks would the tea dumped into
the Boston Harbor during the Boston Tea
Party have affected the underwater
ecosystem
it's an interesting question
I don't know how much tea they dumped in
I mean let's assume it was a few crates
of tea
so the question is how dilute does that
mean the T gets in uh
you know in in the Boston Harbor and the
next question is do fish like tea
you know it's always a funny thing that
different different kinds of animals
respond in different ways to um uh
to chemicals so caffeine for example I
don't know what caffeine does to fish
uh you know one one knows that there's
some weird cases like some particular
kind you know like cats I think do very
badly with Tylenol
um I think because the kidneys of humans
uh kind of filter that out of our
bloodstream but that doesn't work with
cats and so it gets to some kind of
poisonous level I think
um but you know even with things like
spiders you can feed them all kinds of
different drugs caffeine or some other
kinds of drugs you can see they make
different shaped webs depending on what
you know even though they have very very
tiny brains the effect of the brain
function the effect of neuron firings
and things associated with those
different chemicals is enough to make
them make completely different uh sort
of uh whether they you know you can make
a drunk spider will make a weird looking
web so to speak so I don't know what
what um
what tea does to fish in any
concentration one thing that's very
confusing is that usually you would
think with a dilute enough concentration
it's just not going to have any effect
but we know that there are some
chemicals some drugs uh I think LSD is a
notable one where just a single molecule
can have an effect on on on something uh
you know on a on a on uh I don't
actually know how that works now that I
think about it because a single molecule
can have an effect on a single synapse
and a single connection between nerve
cells but we've got 100 billion of those
and so you know how that has a more
Global Effect as a more complicated
story I suppose it may be something a
little bit like the story of black holes
and things where you can have some some
thing where there's sort of a a
propagating effect from that one uh one
place where there's an effect but so you
know this question of well how dilute
does the does the T have to be before
the fish no longer care that there was
tea dumped in the ocean I don't know the
answer to that and it may not be that
the dose response for whatever is in t
will be any kind of sort of linear dose
response you might say see another thing
happens a lot with with drugs with
Pharmaceuticals of various kinds is
there's a non-linear dose response if
you take you know one tenth the
recommended dose it might do absolutely
nothing it doesn't do one-tenth as much
as if you take the recommended dose it's
non-linear and it's not often not very
well understood why that happens you
know examples of why that can happen are
things like well if you put enough of
those molecules in you'll eventually
block everything you know your block a
whole pathway it'll prevent anything
from being transported through some cell
membrane or or being you know
participating in some reaction but if
you only block 10 of it there's still
enough that can get through that
whatever a process it was that was the
big process that was happening can still
happen and you know if you some immune
response or something there's still
enough immune cells that can get through
until you block 100 of it
um it doesn't really work and so that
that's how you can have sort of a
non-linear dose response you have to put
enough in that you get to the point
where you're blocking a hundred percent
and blocking anything less than that
really doesn't have much of a
qualitative effect and so that's how you
can end up with these nonlinear dose
response kinds of Curves and and so I
don't know whether that happens for for
the thick kinds of things which are in
tea
um and I also don't know to what extent
uh you know there are ocean currents and
there's sort of a continual swirling of
the ocean and I don't know how quickly
there's mixing
of water into different parts of the
ocean I mean I know that in general
there's there's quite rapid mixing
between throughout the oceans of the
earth I mean the famous example of this
was when uh nuclear tests were done in
the Pacific Ocean in the 1950s they
produced tritium radioactive isotope of
hydrogen which kind of substituted for
the hydrogens in water in the Pacific in
a you know some a few of the the water
molecules in the Pacific and within just
a few years you could detect tritium in
water all over the Earth so there was
enough mixing between the different
water in the ocean and the Pacific and
in every other kind of water on Earth
that um uh that that that would occur I
have to say that the tritium was
generated in the 1950s bomb tests as
pretty much all decayed Away by now when
I was a kid the amount of tritium that
was sort of said to be in a typical
piece of water was higher than it is
today because of that effect effect
um a very weird phenomenon
um
let's see I think Kappa is asking how
would biologists tests for this I'm not
sure that this might be the effect of um
of some molecule caffeine or something
on a fish you know I think that uh does
it affect the brain well you can start
making measurements from about the the
firing of individual neurons or you can
just see what a fish does and you can
say you know you have a a fish maze or
something and how does the fish go
through the fish maze or how does the uh
you know you see certain behavioral
aspects of fish and you see how much
effect it has it's not an easy thing to
measure really
um
all right maybe one more
question here one from frost Frost
why are the elements on the earth not
more homogeneous why are there areas and
Minds abundance with certain Metals is
the heterogeneity of elements increasing
or decreasing on Earth is it the same
for other planets other galaxies
interesting question I've been curious
about this question in fact I've been
curious enough I've asked a bunch of
geologists and astrogeologists this
exact question so I can tell you some
sort of distribution of world expert
answers kind of converging on one thing
in fact one version of this question
that I've asked is could there be a
golden asteroid
you know people say well we can go mine
minerals Metals whatever from asteroids
but different asteroids will have
different Metals in them and I've asked
you know could there be an asteroid
that's all gold answer is probably not
so
I think what people generally
believe so first point is why are there
like gold mines on Earth why is that you
know gold has a rough abundance of one
part and 10 billion of of all the atoms
in the universe it's like one part in 10
billion well all the atoms that near us
it's one part in 10 billion of gold but
in the earth there's a lot of
concentration of gold into particular
places uh on the earth you know
particular places where we make gold
mines
so gold like all Heavy elements
is pretty much has to be made in
supernovas exploding stars or processes
related to those uh the what happened in
the very early Universe mostly the
universe was just hydrogen and helium uh
the uh you know just individual protons
making hydrogen or helium nuclei roughly
the universe is one quarter helium the
rest is hydrogen and then there's a
trailing amount of of other elements
some bit which were made in the in the
Big Bang in the early Universe the
heavier elements particularly ones past
iron in the periodic table are pretty
much all made in exploding Stars and so
the fact that we have things like gold
on our planet is a consequence of the
fact that our sun wasn't a first
generation star there were other stars
that lived and died before the sun I
mean the sun has a 10 billion year
lifespan we're at about the four billion
year point in that lifespan of about
halfway uh there are other stars
particularly bigger stars that live on
him a few million years like Betelgeuse
there's one such star near us and so
there are there are stars that kind of
come and go and that produce supernovas
produce heavy elements that's where all
the stuff all the gold that we have came
out of some other star that exploded at
some time in the past
so when the earth was formed what
happened is that there was this kind of
uh region of of dust and so on that was
gradually being pulled together by
gravity it Formed an accretion disk it
was spinning around that's how we ended
up with planets kind of more or less in
a plane all orbiting around in the same
direction
um it formed this this disc and
different parts of it would Clump into a
planet and other planets and so on well
depending on lots of details about the
density of things and this and that and
the other exactly how far out they were
in this disc you know how did things get
sort of vacuumed up by one thing that
was kind of a massive object that was
pulling in other massive objects I think
in the end the Earth as it was formed as
this kind of giant amalgam of different
kinds of objects that were formed at
different distances out from the Sun and
so on and whose orbits were not just
circular but whose orbits were more comp
located and things would gradually sort
of crash into each other and all make
make themselves into this Big Blob of of
stuff
now
then what happened is well the Earth
uh that that sort of it's it's the fact
that the Earth is kind of a clump
together of all these different pieces
that I think is the first step in making
it not heterogeneous
now the second thing was perhaps a
little bit confusing is when the moon
was formed the current best theory for
how the moon was formed is something
very bizarre it's kind of a two-step
thing it's well first the earth was
formed and then some other little thing
crashed into the Earth
and it's you know a thing maybe a little
bit smaller than Mars or something
crashed into the Earth and that kind of
disrupted the earth a lot and it made
the Earth kind of uh you know turn
liquid and so on and then another it
kind of that that ejected this big piece
of stuff from the Earth
which wound up then forming into the
moon and actually the Moon
unlike the Earth the Moon is not very
homogeneous the Earth is is reasonably
if you look at the gravity of the earth
you have a spacecraft going around the
earth it kind of orbits at room more or
less the same height all around the
earth the moon that's not true one side
of the moon is denser than the other
side there's kind of a it's like the
Moon is two things that got stuck
together and that's probably from this
big Splat that happened when the moon
was formed or at least that's the theory
of it so the moon really has a very
inhomogeneous there's two very
inhomogeneous pieces stuck together the
Earth probably melted at one point and
then re-frows again it's still molten
and the core of the earth is still
molten and probably there are sort of
detailed processes associated with the
motion of of of the molten core of the
earth and so on that had a different
effect for some uh depending on the
densities of materials and things like
this and eventually there are chemical
processes that will and to concentrate
things in one place rather than another
so in the question of whether that's
true you know if we go mining on the
moon or we go mining on Mars we find the
same kind of oh there's a tantalum mine
here and so on that's an interesting
question actually I have not
specifically asked that question
um whether the big Splat will have had
an effect on the homogeneity of the
earth I don't know and the fact that the
Earth has a liquid core might have an
effect Mars does not have a liquid core
the moon does not have a liquid core
um well Mars might have a tiny one but
the moons doesn't seem to have one at
all and uh that's something we know from
just like from earthquakes on the earth
we can tell that when there's one place
on the Earth where there's big
earthquake we can see how the seismic
waves propagate through the Earth and we
can see that the that in the core of the
earth there's something liquid because
different kinds of waves go through
liquids then go through solids and so on
the moon uh there are little Moon Quakes
that happen they're smaller than
earthquakes but we can see from that
that there doesn't seem to be anything
that it seems to be that they propagate
through the moon as a solid object
so that that's kind of the um
the story of of um uh uh yeah that's so
so I'm guessing it's an interesting
question I'm sort of guessing
the first approximation they'll be
mining on Mars like there's mining on
Earth
second approximation it might not be the
same because of the big Splat and things
like that
um and it might very well be that um and
some of these planets and moons that get
continually so squidged by by tidal
forces and so on they may have kind of
separated out different materials and
and different minerals and so on in
different ways it's a good question
as you can tell I thought it's a good
question because I've asked it a bunch
of people trying to get to a definitive
answer but I'm I'm telling you that the
best I know so far all right I gotta go
to uh something for my day job but thank
you for a lot of interesting questions
and um I hope people found that
interesting and uh look forward to
chatting with you another time
bye for now